I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks so
much for spending some time with us hide
and go leak that's the focus of
tonight's
angle all right we all love playing hide
and go seek at least I did as kids
especially as the sun was setting on a
beautiful summer day well it's
wintertime and the adults in charge in
the Senate are still playing games this
one's called Hide and Go leak as in hi
the text of the so-called Senate border
deal while leaking out bits and pieces
and what's a transparent attempt to
satisfy critics now it's a classic
Senate theater of the Absurd move with
its own cast of characters including the
Man cast by Mitch McConnell to be lead
actor that's Oklahoma senator Jim
Langford he's trying mightily to
convince you that Biden will really
enforce new laws under a new bill even
though he doesn't use the authority that
he already has
now under the leaked out language Biden
would not be compelled not be compelled
to act to close the border unless a
threshold number of about 5,000 migrants
had been logged in one day which by the
way has happened many times during the
past month this is not about letting
5,000 people in a day this is the most
misunderstood section of this proposal
let me tell you briefly what it is in
the last four months we've had 7 Days in
4 months we've had 7 days that we had
less than 5,000 people this is set up
for if you have a rush of people coming
at the border the Border closes down no
one gets in now his arguments make no
sense because in the first place as even
the Washington Post uh on this subject
made clear even the 5,000 migrant cap
isn't a real cap because even if the
Border were shut down people could apply
for a Asylum at ports of Entry so the
Border would never be shut down no
matter how high the number gets and as
for the idea that we can trust Biden and
my orcus to implement pro- enforcement
changes and Asylum laws there is zero
reason for us to believe that either of
them would want this nonsense stopped
unless well of course every ensuring
that everyone meets the new standard if
there was a new standard put in place
after all 90% of all migrants right now
do not qualify for Asylum status they
just mouth the credible fear language in
the regulation yeah they've been tutored
plus Biden would still be allowed to
parole migrants into the country in huge
numbers even the Washington Post
conceded this saying some Republicans
goal to dramatically curtail Biden's use
of his own humanitarian parole powers
for certain categories of migrants is
not in the final
deal okay think about this this Biden's
parole power will be
unchanged and he'll get his $60 billion
for
Ukraine leave it to the Senate
Republicans to call that a good deal
conservatives essentially get nothing
they want and liberals get everything
they want oh but wait because Senator
Langford says that the bill would
allocate more money for immigration
judges and other Personnel you know what
I say to that so what more staff just
gives Biden the chance to hire a bunch
of woke people who will do everything
possible to help bring more migrants
into the country because that's how this
works the notion that Biden or Langford
are going to use that money to hire
really tough border people like Tom
Holman in favor of enforcement that's
absurd it is interesting Republicans
four months ago would not give funding
for Ukraine for Israel and for our
Southern border because we demanded
changes in policy so we actually locked
arms together and said we're not going
to give you money for this we want to
change in law and now it's interesting a
few months later when we're finally get
to the end they're like oh just kidding
I actually don't want to change in law
because it's a presidential election
year well that's categorically false
we're against this deal because it's a
bad deal it's so bad that his team
refuses to release the text and oh yes
they have the text and they won't
release it until the last possible
minute we know it's going to be with
ambiguous language and countless
exceptions to any supposedly tough
border Provisions so this bill whatever
is text is unnecessary and
indefensible to prove his bonafides On
the Border Biden could shut down the
border right now he could declare a
national border emergency citing
fentanyl overdoses overcrowded cities
health concerns overcrowded schools but
he doesn't do this in Langford company
won't demand it why well John Kirby got
tripped up today on this
question are there not steps that he
could use under executive authority to
some measures uh to kind of seal some of
the Border efforts he he said he's he's
willing to use executive measures and um
and you know if he gets if he gets the
the bill passed if he gets border
funding and and it and includes those
authorities he'll use those authorities
hey John
next time just say uh can I buy a vowel
please now back to Langford now he's a
senator from one of our most
conservative States so has he convened a
town hall in Oklahoma on this border
Bill really go through it of course not
but why not release the language then
try to go sell it to the people who will
actually have to live with the
consequences he won't do a town hall
because he knows how bad badly it would
go on Saturday the Oklahoma GOP voted to
formally censure Langford accusing him
of playing fast and loose with Democrats
on our border policy not only
disenfranchises legal immigrants seeking
citizenship but it also puts the Safety
and Security of Americans in great
danger It Goes On by the way to call on
him to cease and desist jeopardizing the
security and Liberty of Americans the
angle could not agree
more stop the hiding stop the leaking
and focus on uniting Republicans and
Independence maybe disaffected Democrats
to win in November and finally do what
the people have wanted for 20 years to
have a real border and limited
immigration and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else